Horsebird Refection Wo geht ihr alle hin?
Bleibt doch hier.
Bleibt doch hier. Wir wollten euch doch nur füttern. Das grosse Problem, die meisten Leute hauen nach dem Intro ab, deswegen herzlich willkommen jetzt unseren treuen Kern beim Hauptteil. Schön, dass ihr mit dabei seid. Mir ging immer natürlich wie immer Stefan, Thaddeus, Maria, Tietze, hallo. Und gegenüber von mir, Florentin David-Pascal, Will Nurek, hallo herzlich willkommen, Florentin, danke fürs Vorbeischneiden. Wobei ich muss auch sagen, Tauben füttern sieht auch ein bisschen aus, also die Grenze zwischen Tauben füttern und Tauben bewerfen ist sehr überfies. Ich habe manchmal das Gefühl, Tauben mögen es auch ein bisschen gröber. Ich glaube, die mögen es auch, wenn man so sagt, hier, komm, nimm es, nimm es. Naja, nee, ist aber nicht deine Entscheidung, wie die Tauben das finden, sondern es müssen die Tauben selber entscheiden, wie sie das finden. Ja, das ist natürlich völlig richtig, aber das ist einfach meine Erfahrung. Deine Erfahrung ist, die wollen sie ein bisschen härter. Tauben sind sehr skeptische Lebewesen, wenn man denen das so hinlegt, die denken sich, nee, komm, so nicht. Also du musst eine klare Zeichen, meinst du? Hier, nimm! Ja, du musst ganz klar zeigen, dass du gar nicht irgendwelche positiven Gefühle vortäuscht, sondern dass diese Hassbeziehung klar ist. Wie hältst du im Straßenverkehr auf Tauben drauf, sitzen häufig auf der Straße?
Voll drauf.
Auch hier meinst du lieber, die wollen es hart, du willst lieber ein klares Zeichen geben,
ich bremse nicht für Tauben, das ist auch dein Sticker, den du hinten auf deinem dann doch relativ gross geratenen Van hast.
Was ich gelernt habe in meinen vielen, vielen Lebensjahren, die ich jetzt schon auf diesem blauen, herrlichen Ball herumtolle.
Was meinen wir eigentlich, das wollen wir den Leuten erklären mit unseren 27-Jährchen? Ich habe gelernt, Tauben kennen ihre Grenzen. Verdammt gut. Die wissen genau, was los ist. Ja, wenn du da schön mit meinem Lamborghini draufballert, die wissen ganz genau, in letzter Sekunde müssen sie aufspringen. Wer auch seine Grenzen kennt, sind natürlich die herrlichen Komponisten dieses tollen Intros. Mattes und Philipp, eine Kollaboration, wie wir sie schon lange nicht mehr gesehen haben. Sie haben sich wieder zusammengefunden nach dem Bruch 2019. Mattes und Philipp. Ja, vielen Dank an Mattes und Philipp für dieses fantastische Intro. Was meinst du, wer hat mehr gemacht von den beiden? Mattes. Mattes schon, ne? Wobei ich auch nochmal hier Frage stellen möchte, ob unsere HörerInnen Intros schon mal gehört haben. Nicht, weil sie so andersartig sind, sondern weil sie eher länger sind.
Genau.
Ihr müsst weniger machen.
Ein kurzes Beispiel-Intro.
I can't do this all on my own.
No, I know, I'm no Superman.
Ende.
Ende, fucking Ende.
Aus.
Harter Schnitt.
Und dann kommen die Lacher.
So.
Ende.
Hier ein anderes Intro, was... Baauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauauau na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na Hör auf! Flot hin auf!
Das ist ganz
Na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, Jesus Christ, es geht noch zehn Minuten.
Na, na, man skippt na, na, na, na, na, na. Game of Thrones ist so ein Intro, dass wenn ich das wegskippe, meistens zu wenig skippe und dann noch im Intro bin.
Ja.
Aber dann lasse ich es auch laufen, weil ich denke, ja, ist auch catchy.
Bald geht es wieder los, ne? Also wir leben in einer wild lasse ich es auch laufen, weil ich denke, ja, ist auch catchy. Bald geht es wieder los.
Also wir leben in einer wilden Zeit.
Dieser September wird, glaube ich, einiges verändern.
Es gibt eine Game of Thrones Serie, es gibt eine Star Wars Serie,
es gibt eine Herr der Ringe Serie, drei der grössten und beliebtesten Franchises der Welt.
Es gibt eine Star Wars Serie.
Ach der Zynismo!
Erzähl mir mehr von der neuen Star Wars Serie. Zu viele gute Dinge sind für mich schlecht. Ich bin Stefan Tütze. Uh, Kulturpessimist. Oh nein, Unterhaltung! Weg von mir! Der Zynismus kommt rein! Weg von mir! Um Gottes Willen eine, was soll ich denn? Wow, noch eine Star Wars Serie! Ich möchte! Wow, schrecklich, schrecklich, schrecklich. Ja. Also wir wünschen euch viel Spaß damit auf jeden Fall. Ich bin gespannt. Also was ich zu meiner Verteidigung sagen möchte, also das ist ja Banane-Quatsch, den du gerade hier rumlaberst. Also auf die Hellring-Serie freue ich mich total, ehrlich gesagt. Aber dass du hier so groß mit Nachrichtenwert ankündigst, wow, es gibt eine neue Star Wars Serie.
Im selben Monat, die Guillermo del Toro Horror Serie kommt auch, Guillermo del Horror kommt auch zurück.
Guillermo del Horror ist zurück.
Kommt alles zurück, alles in einem Monat. Das ist vielleicht rückblickend, dass Woodstock von unserer Zeit, wenn man sagt, wow, in diesem einen Monat ist so viel passiert, so viele tolle Serien sind da gekommen.
Kommen wir doch direkt zu einer Rubrik. Zur Schlagzeile der Woche, denn ich weiß nicht, ob ihr es mitbekommen habt. Das ist das Podcast-Überflor und ich weiß nicht, warum wir so eine News-Ecke anmoderieren. Es gab mal Zeiten, in denen hatten wir nicht so riesige Probleme wie Es kommen zu viele Serien raus, die ich mir angucken kann. Es gab Zeiten, in denen haben wir unbeschwerter gelebt. Da war die einzige Frage nur noch Team Edward oder Team Wolf. Snowden. Bist du Team Vorname oder Team Nachname? Nee, Team Edward oder Team Jacob? Team Jacob, genau. Wir erinnern uns alle Twilight, der grosse Teenie-Hit damals.
Und jetzt natürlich guckt man auch zurück skeptischer. Denn ich war immer Team Edward, aber natürlich muss man auch sagen, warum jetzt genau, weil du die Filme gesehen hast und den sexy Guy. Du findest, jetzt mal ganz ohne Spaß, jetzt leg mal deine, nee, nee, leg mal deine zu Schlitzen geformten, weggelegt,ten Zynismusaugen kurz mal weg. Du findest Edward hotter als Jacob. Das ist bei mir genau andersrum. Robert Pattinson für mich immer ein Sexgott. Taylor Lautner sieht besser aus, finde ich. So, und Taylor Lautner hat jetzt geheiratet und seine Ehegattin heisst auch Taylor mit Vornamen.
Und jetzt kam diese Woche die Schlagzeile raus, seine Ehefrau nimmt auch seinen Nachnamen an und heisst jetzt auch Taylor Lordner. Also wir haben jetzt das Ehepaar Lordner, bei dem sowohl Ehemann als auch Ehefrau beide Taylor Lautner heißen. Das ist jetzt nicht so hilfreich für alle Beteiligten. Was Fantastisches. Naja, es ist einfacher für die Einladungen zur Hochzeit gewesen. Auf jeden Fall. Es ist einfacher zu sagen, willst du Taylor Lautner, man kann das alles abkürzen ein bisschen. Riesenproblem für mich die Post. Was ist, wenn ein Brief ankommt für Taylor Lautner, wer darf den aufmachen von den beiden? Was ist, wenn ich jetzt Taylor wäre, angenommen, ich bin Taylor, will eine süße Überraschung für Taylor, Geburtstag kommt drauf, und jetzt will ich für Taylor was Süsses bestellen, wird nicht funktionieren, weil die Post kommt an und Taylor macht's auf.
Und sagt, hä, neue Bettwäsche?
Ach, das war doch für Taylor.
Das war doch nicht für dich, Taylor, sondern für mich.
Nee, Taylor, das war für mich, Taylor.
Es ist grossartig, es ist schwierig. Oder gibt's Nuancen in der Aussprache?
Nein, nein.
Du bist dir sicher, dass es wieder... Beide Taylor-Lortner. Nee, aber so wie Taylor und Tyler zum Beispiel. Und dann habe ich mich ein bisschen reingekniet in dieses Thema. Namensding. Und zwar stellt sich raus, 2010 war Taylor-Lortner mit Taylor Swift liiert. Das glaube ich. Wir haben so einen Rebecca-Case, den wir vor.... Wir haben einen Rebecca-Case. Also, ich glaube, dass es von Taylor Lautner langfristig schon geplant war, dass er Taylor-stated. Für diesen Gag. Und er war tatsächlich mit Taylor Swift liiert, was verheiratet bedeutet, oder? Ich glaube nicht. Sondern verlobt. Nee, zusammen. Liiert? Ich glaube, es gibt keine klare Definition von liiert. Eine Liaison, ein Liebesverhältnis eingegangen. Ah, okay. Dann habe ich das Wort mein Leben ... Oder eine sich zum Zwecke einer geschäftlichen Zusammenarbeit mit jemandem verbinden. Man kann ihm auch so vorwerfen, dass er sich zum Zwecke einer geschäftlichen Zusammenarbeit mit ihr verbunden hätte, habe. Gut, so oder so habe ich das Wort mein Leben lang falsch verwendet, kein Problem. Aber ich glaube, das ist langfristig von ihm geplant. Er wollte schon immer einen zweiten Taylor-Lortner auf dieser Welt sehen und hat gesagt, ein Taylor-Lortner ist nicht genug, ich will, dass noch jemand Taylor-Lortner heißt. Also man kennt das ja bei Leuten, die auf dem Datingmarkt eher nach Leuten suchen, die ähnlich aussehen wie sie selbst. Das kennt man ja. Dem liegt, finde ich, immer so Narzissmus zugrunde und ich beschuldige diese Person noch immer des Narzissmus.
Ihr wollt eigentlich nur euch selber daten, aber das ist jetzt eine neue Form, also den eigenen Namen daten zu wollen.
Es ist wahnsinnig. Ich finde das schwierig.
Vor allem, ich glaube, jemand wie Terry Lordner kann ja jeden haben. Das heißt, natürlich musst du dir schon so eine Art Quest überlegen, wen möchte ich jetzt, weil der kriegt natürlich hunderte, der ist ja aufgewachsen als Teenie-Star, der lebt ja mit dem Gefühl, alle Frauen wollen mich haben. Das heißt, der muss schon, um überhaupt selektieren oder sortieren zu können, muss er ja schon so ein paar Filter anbringen, weil sonst wirst du dieser Masse ja nie Herr. Teaser, Teaser, Teaser. Kommen wir zu unserem Werbepartner, Teser. Teser oder Teser-Film, äh, These, wie wär's denn, wenn er einfach ein sehr eifersüchtiger Mensch ist und gern immer eine Ausrede hätte, ach, das war dein Handy, nee, ich hab nur geguckt kurz, weil da stand, hey, Taylor, und ich wollte nur kurz die Nachrichten lesen. Ja, Taylor, du weißt doch, welcher Taylor du bist.
Ich habe extra für uns beide das gleiche Handy, also wir haben ja beide das zufällige
gleiche Handy und so.
Und ich kann mir einfach vorstellen, dass er sehr eifersüchtig ist, die Post gerne
aufmacht von des anderen Taylors.
Hast du schon wieder meinen Hut an?
Ach so, genau, er ist auch sehr eifersüchtig auf die Mode von ihr und will dann auch die
gleichen Sachen.
Einfach so komplett verschmelzen, vielleicht will man komplett verschmelzen mit seinem Partner und einfach eine Person werden irgendwann. Das ist aber generell sowieso, finde ich das Ziel immer bei Pärchen. Dass man eine Person werden? Ja, also so, das geben dann die beiden nicht zu, aber es passiert häufig, diese Selbstaufgabe, dieses Verschmelzen zu einem neuen Individuum, wo ich sage, stopp, nein, das soll doch nicht sein. Moment, sind wir gerade in Stefan-Fick-Tipps eigentlich? Wir sind in Stefans-Fick-Tipps. Das hat doch unsere, merkwürdigerweise der falsche Name für unsere Beziehungsrubrik. Nee, wo ich sagen muss, das hat aufzuhören, diese Selbstaufgabe in Beziehungen bleibt zwei Individuen, langfristig habt ihr davon mehr. Das mag sich am Anfang vielleicht ein bisschen falsch anfühlen, den Partner unnötig auf Distanz zu halten. Ich glaube, das ist keine unnötige Distanz, ich glaube, es ist eine dringend notwendige Distanz, um das Individuum zu wahren. Da war dann auch davor, dass wenn dann mal die Beziehung auseinander geht, man nicht zu sehr auf verlorenen Posten steht. Gut, dann machen wir das so, wie Stefan das will.
Leben wir alle so, wie Stefan will.
So heißt nämlich die Rubrik
Beziehungstipps.
Lebt alle so, wie Stefan das will.
Aber da dachte ich mir, wie wichtig sind eigentlich Zweitnamen?
Weil es kann ja immer passieren, dass du jemanden heiratest,
der genauso heisst wie du.
Tolle Frage.
Und dann musst du dich eigentlich immer auf Zweitnamen konzentrieren. Probleme, die heißen beide Kim. Taylor Kim Lautner. Taylor Kim Lautner, Taylor Kay. Ah, wer? Ja, es ist schwierig, aber du brauchst coole Zweitnamen, die im Zweifel auch erhalten können. Als Unterscheidungsmöglichkeit. Mhm. Oder wenn du Fantasy-Autor werden willst, brauchst du zwei Zweitnamen, die den gleichen Buchstaben haben. Ja, oder Logos, habe ich auch schon gedacht. Fussballer haben ja inzwischen eigene Logos, die sind immer ein bisschen peinlich. Ja, und zwar, wenn es dann so Richtung Merge geht oder so, oder die kriegen dann von Adidas oder Nike eine eigene Modelinie, dann wird deren Logo draufgedrückt. Oder aber auch bei Formel 1, dein neues Lieblingssujet, auch da haben die dann ihre eigenen Logos. Meistens ist es aber nur der Vorname irgendwie kreativ verbunden mit dem Anfangsbuchstaben des Nachnamens. Ach so, aber kann man dann auch so ikonografisch arbeiten? Also wenn jetzt so ein Georg Müller dann irgendwie so eine Müller so eine Mühle hat oder sowas? Genau. Also dass du dann zumindest bei Leuten, die einen Namen haben, mit Michael Götze kann dann irgendwie so ein Schrumpfkopf schwierig einzusetzen, aber man kann sich da schon was ausdenken. Es gibt ja auch so Websites, wo man sich ganz günstig Logos kreieren kann, da könnt ihr ja mal drauf schauen. Friedrich Schweinsteiger hat so ein kleines Schweinchen.
Genau, bei Müller fände ich jetzt nicht schlecht, wenn die Ü-Punkte von so einem Mühlenkreuz ersetzt würden.
Aber zum Beispiel unser Lieblingsfahrer der Formel 1, Landon Norris, hat ein ganz tolles Logo.
Und da muss ich sagen, das ist, finde ich, das beste Logo von allen.
Jetzt muss ich das mal finden, wie googelt man denn dieses Logo? Und da muss ich sagen, das ist, finde ich, das beste Logo von allen. Jetzt muss ich das mal finden, wie googelt man dieses Logo? Unmöglich. Weil... Ach so, einfach so ein L und ein N. Das ist das L, das N, ja genau, wie immer, aber der Dead Space dazwischen ergibt die vier, seine Zahl. Ja, und der kann nicht irgendwie einen Millennium-Falken, der durchgestrichen ist, machen, oder? Nochmal kurz. Das ist unmöglich, oder wie, sich das als Logos zu nehmen.
Chewbacca, Han und der Millennium-Falken durchgestrichen.
Nee, aber nochmal zurückkommen, das hast du gerade nicht mitbekommen, es ging ein bisschen unter.
Der Dead Space zwischen den beiden Buchstaben ist die vier, seine Zahl.
Und das finde ich wiederum eine clevere Sache.
Das ist cool.
Wohingegen alle anderen prominenten
Initial-Logos eher scheiße sind,
weil die immer Anfangsbuchstabe
irgendwie kreativ verbunden mit dem zweiten
Buchstaben. Und das finde ich
ein bisschen bescheuert.
Ja, das ist alles Dürer, ne?
Es läuft alles zurück auf Dürer.
Es ist alles Albrecht Dürer, der gesagt hat,
ich unterschreibe nicht nur mit meinem Namen,
sondern mit einem coolen Logo. Wir haben allerdings gleich einen Podcast, glaube ich, gehört, durch ganz Deutschland ging diese Anekdote. Dürer hat, glaube ich, dann tatsächlich das Logo erfunden. Ja, der hat das Logo erfunden und auch gewisserweise Personalmarketing, also sich selber auch als Marke darzustellen. Klar, ich meine, es gab immer Familienwappen und so, aber die haben natürlich mehr als nur das Individuum beschrieben, aber so, Dürer hat angefangen mit dem ganzen Kram. Wie gefällt dir das Logo von Dürer, jetzt zurückblickend? Ich glaube, da wäre mehr drin gewesen, um ganz ehrlich zu sein. Ich finde es auch eher schwach. Also du hast das große A und in dem großen Hohlraum von A hast du das kleine D. Er ist das wirklich, er ist genau das, was ich meine. Er ist genau wie Mario Götzes, Cristiano Ronaldos der Welt, mit ihren eigenen Witten-Emblants. Ja, vor allem das A sieht dadurch sehr hässlich aus, weil es sich sehr nach oben verzogen hat, weil es halt Platz machen muss für das D. Das wirkt irgendwie so, als wärst du an den Rand gedrängt. Das A hat keinen Raum Atmen irgendwie. Vor allem, lange gibt es die Albrecht-Dürer-Schule, die sich aber entschieden hat, nicht seinem Logo zu folgen. Das ist schon gemein. Aber Albrecht-Dürer hat auch das TM vergessen, das kleine. Und das A hat auch so eine Art Dach oben dr schon, also ich weiß nicht, ob man das damals so gemacht hat oder ob das auch fancy ist.
Ich finde das Albrecht-Dürer-Logo sieht aus wie so ein alter japanischer Schrein mit einem D.
Bisschen, ja, wie dieser Torbogen.
Genau. Nun gut, ähm.
Also nicht mein Favorit.
Lassen wir Dürer mal Dürer sein.
Aber?
Lass uns diese Dürer-Rubrik da mal die Dürer zumachen, dann haben wir es auch. Aber nur falls dich ganz kurz als Abschluss interessiert, wie die Unterschrift von Taylor Lautner aussieht, so. Also ganz viele Striche auf dem Papier. Ganz viele Linien, und ich finde es auch gut, dass ab einem gewissen Standing man auf Wikipedia auch seine Unterschrift präsentiert, dass er auch so eine Art Pseudo-Logo ist. Wie kommt das denn zustande? Ja, Identitätsdiebstahl. Man sagt im Grunde, wenn jemand meine Unterschrift... Ich habe tatsächlich schon früh Leuten um mich herum gesagt, unterschreibt für mich. Weil ich habe, als Kind lernt man natürlich auch die Unterschrift seiner Eltern, klar, aber auch andersrum finde ich es gut, wenn andere Leute für einen unterschreiben könnten. Deswegen sage ich auch immer hier, gerade bei so digitalen Unterschriften bin ich mal ganz ehrlich, die Datei ist recht frei verfügbar. Die Datei, meine Unterschrift liegt in der Dropbox, sage ich mal. So, und dann können jeder, der unterschreiben muss, kann sich die einfach holen. Es liegt in der Dropbox, das neue liegt auf der Strasse. In gewisser Weise, ja. Der Gag lag in der Dropbox. Der lag wirklich für alle verfügbare Drobo. Ja, ansonsten ist nicht viel passiert die Woche. Nee, aber das möchte ich kurz noch mal einhaken. Wie kommt das denn zustande, dass plötzlich die Unterschriften und Prominenten auf Wikipedia... Ich glaube, es hat angefangen mit Präsidenten, weil du als Präsident natürlich dir schon was überlegen musst. Aber wie ist der Vorgang? Weil die sind ja auch transparent. Ja, das stimmt, die sind freigestellt. Genau, da verstehe ich jetzt nicht genau, wie das funktioniert. Das schreiben die auf so einem grossen Wikipedia-Pad. Und dann sagt Wikipedia, Dankeschön, wir stellen uns jetzt online oder so. Was ist der Mehrwert überhaupt von der Unterschrift? Bei Taylor Swift hast du keine Unterschrift, obwohl man ja sagen könnte, Taylor Swift ist der grössere Name alsner. Also von der großen Liste der Taylors ist das ja ein wichtigerer Name. Taylor Swift hat nicht ihre Unterschrift, auf der deutschen Wikipedia zumindest. Taylor Lautner hat seine Unterschrift sogar auf der deutschen Wikipedia. Wie ist das passiert? Aber jetzt finde ich es viel geiler, wenn sie die Tochter von Steven Tyler geiratet hätte. So, jetzt wird kurz gegoogelt.
Gebt uns kurz zu, wir hätten es alles vorher machen können.
Gebt uns kurz ...
Angenommen, Taylor-Lotten hätte Liv Tyler geheiratet.
Oh ja.
Auch nicht schlecht.
Und ihr Namen angenommen, dann wäre er Taylor-Tyler.
Taylor-Tyler wäre richtig gut gewesen, ja. In gewisser Weise aber nicht so geil. Aber der beste Name ist eh Swift, oder? Also wer will denn nicht Swift heißen? Oder ist ja nicht ihr Name, oder? Wie? Die hat ja bestimmt Swiffering. Swiffer? Oder Swiffer-Ranson und hat ihn jetzt einfach angenommen auf Swift. Letzte Google-Suche für heute. Ach, Steven Tyler heißt gar nicht Steven. Doch, Taylor, Alison Swift. Die heißt Swift. Die ist Swift. Swift. Egal, dass Liv Tyler auf einem Aerosmith-Konzert erfahren hat, dass der Frontsänger Steven Tyler ihr Vater ist. Echt? Ja, ja, da ist sie mit ihr hingegangen auf ein Aerosmith-Konzert, da war eine riesen Band schon Stadion gefüllt, vorne diese unglaublich charismatische Frontsänger mit einer der besten Stimmen für Rockmusik der ganzen Welt. Und dann plötzlich sagte jemand, ja, Standdad. Wer hat das gesagt? Einfach jemand aus der Menge? Nee, ich weiß nicht, wer mit ihr hingegangen ist. Wow. Vielleicht findet man das irgendwo. Aber ist es nicht auch so, wenn sein Vater irgendwie so berühmt ist, dass man den dann nicht cool findet oder so? Also das höre ich immer wieder von so krassen Rockstars, die dann sagen, meine Kinder finden mich richtig uncool. Irgendwie von Zeppelin. Led. Von LED Zeppelin. Gibt es eine LED-Firma, die LED Zeppelin heißt? Ja. Okay. 80 Prozent meiner LEDs kriege ich von LED Zeppelin eigentlich. Ich möchte wissen, wo sie das erfahren hat, dass es ihr Vater ist und wer sie da hingeschleppt hat. Ihr könnt die heutige Folge übrigens komplett auf Google rekonstruieren. Ihr könnt die auf Wikipedia. Wir bieten die Folge auch als Text an. Einfach diese sieben Google-Suchen schließen euch mehr oder weniger die gesamte Folge. Dadurch könnt ihr das selber nachbauen. Das ist so ein bisschen Google nach Zahlen, wo ihr eigentlich alles kriegt. Die Folge wird rausgekramt, wenn man irgendwann fragt, wann war der Untergang des Podcasts eingeläutet. Genau, wann war der Jumping-the-Shark-Moment, wo es abwärts ging? Da, wo sich alle gar keine Mühe gemacht haben und während der Folge auch angefangen, aufgehört haben zu reden und zu googeln. Das war, glaube ich, der Moment. Auch Privatgespräche irgendwann durchkamen. Falls es nach dem Podcast nicht weitergeht, für dich und so, ich habe überlegt, falls es irgendwann mal ein Ende geben soll, du Podcast, ich habe, glaube ich, eine coole Idee für dich. Danke, okay, das ist nett für dich. Hostelbesitzer. Du meinst, wieder Horrorfilm? Nee. Nee, Hostelbesitzer. Weil du erzählst ja immer, wenn du mal irgendwann Kino besitzt, dann setzt du da genau deine Regeln um und so. Und ich war in einem Hostel jetzt im Urlaub, wo auch ein Typ exakt seine Regeln umgesetzt hat.
Und es war so hart, also es war so lustig, weil er hat dann auch so eine große Tafel gehabt, wo drauf stand, keine Guitars, keine Flip-Flops, keine Ponchos. So, und er macht in Peru einen Hostel auf, aber er setzte so klein um. Ja.
Und als ich da war, gab es verschiedene Momente, wo Leute, die da gebucht haben, hingekommen sind, sich einchecken wollten, hatten aber ein Poncho an und sie wurden rausgesprochen.
Und ich denke mir, das ist so, also er hat das so gelebt, als wäre er so der Bürgermeister von Hostel City und setzt das so um.
Und dann war auch so, weil er wohnte ja auch auf dem Gelände, weil das ja sein Privates ist, und er hat gesagt, check in bis maximal 19 Uhr, sonst fliegt er hier raus. Ja, danach läuft Pink Panther, dann habe ich keine Zeit mehr. Ich meine, ich will Fernsehen gucken, ich will mein Leben leben und will anfangen, mit dem Wein aufzumachen. Dann kamen Leute um 19.02 Uhr und er sagt, nein, und dann bist du halt am Arsch der Welt, weil sein Hostel war nicht irgendwie eine Stadt, eine Großstadt,, das war am Arsch der Heide und da gibt es kein anderes Hostel, dann kannst du schön wieder eine Stunde lang wegfahren und aber ich finde das knallhart umgesetzt und wir hatten da eine mega Zeit und es war sehr, sehr lustig, aber ich dachte die ganze Zeit, eigentlich der lebt seinen Traum, ach das ist wirklich ein Traum, so und dann fing es aber an, dann setzt er sich immer dann zu seinen Gästen und fängt dann auch ein bisschen rumzulabern und er will schon immer im Mittelpunkt sein und man merkt das schon, also er ist schon sehr, ja, egozentristisch da unterwegs und dann plötzlich am letzten Abend fing es dann an, hat er dann angefangen Corona zu leugnen, vor allem. Immer dieser letzte Abend. Der berühmte letzte Abend. Also unser letzter Abend, andere mussten noch viel länger bleiben.
Aber und ich war immer so, ich bin ein harmoniebedürftiger Kerl und wollte mich nicht mit ihm anlegen. Und ich habe rennt seit seinen Regeln runtergespult, so auswendig, wie ich packe meinen Koffer, wenn ich auswendig gelernt habe, damit ich nicht miteinander rassle. Ich kann das nicht ertragen. Na klar. Und dann war ich immer sehr nett zu ihm und habe über alle seine Witze gelacht, bis es dann irgendwann anfangen mit Covid, da wurde es dann problematisch, da kippte das dann. Und dann hat er auch noch angefangen, gegen Israel zu labern und dann wurde es plötzlich sehr unangenehm und ich habe den Traum verlassen dann und habe mir was gekocht. Mit meinen Flip-Flops und meinem Ponschen den Traum verlassen. Und dann... Demonstrativ die Flip-Flops angezogen. Angezogen, für Israel die Flip-Flops angezogen. Ja, und dann haben wir im Nachhinein gesagt, das geht eigentlich nicht, also wir müssen jetzt einen negativen Kommentar schreiben. Und das war das einzige Hostel, wo wir danach einen negativen Kommentar ausgeleiert haben. Und dann sind wir auf die Seite gegangen und da muss man erstmal so Sachen bewerten wie Sauberkeit, das allgemeine Klima da, also Atmosphäre, Aussicht und so. Es war alles super, also viele gute Bewertungen gegeben und so. Dann der Host war halt nicht so toll, wenig gute Bewertungen. Dann haben wir einen Text geschrieben, was alles gut lief und dass am letzten Abend leider die Stimmung getrübt wurde durch Covid und Anti-Israel-Brabbelei. Und dann haben wir den Text einmal weitergeklickt und dann wurde er schon veröffentlicht. Was ich dachte, was dann nochmal kommt, ist, dass man den Aufenthalt allgemein bewertet. Es kam aber nicht. Was dann dazu führte, dass da jetzt dieser Text steht, wo am Ende steht, ja und am Ende wurden Anti-Israel-Sachen gesagt, Bewertung 8,3 grossartig. Von Simon aus Deutschland, weil das hat mein Kumpel gemacht. Und dann habe ich gedacht, das liest sich jetzt total bescheuert. Haben wir denn erwähnt, dass wir das schlecht finden, dass er das gemacht hat? Naja, weil wir haben halt, den Rest haben wir total ehrlich beantwortet und es war halt super sauber. Die Betten waren ganz, ganz toll. Das ganze Hostel war klasse eingerichtet, die Leute da waren toll, der Host war halt scheiße, hat so eine Gesamtbewertung von 8,3 grossartig geführt und jetzt liest es sich so, wow, bis auf der Antisemitismus, der war furchtbar, 8,3 grossartig. Auf eine Art und dann steht ja noch drunter Simon Germany. Wo man sich denkt, ja gut, die Besucher kamen halt jetzt nicht aus Israel, wir hatten jetzt keine Probleme damit. Ja. Also es liest sich ganz, ganz schlimm. Und deswegen, ich weiß nicht, an wenn ich mich jetzt richten will damit, ich möchte nur sagen, guckt genau, gibt es am Ende nochmal eine Gesamtbewertung und vielleicht, wenn ihr so eine Hotel-Website oder so eine Reisetrip-Bewertungs-Website seid, am besten einfach nochmal so ein allgemein, was man dann geben würde. Ja, das ist immer schwierig, dieses differenzierte Bewerten, auch so bei Lieferdiensten oder irgendwie sowas. Ja, das Essen war schrecklich, katastrophal, furchtbar, aber schnell geliefert. Vier Sterne. Ja genau, schnell, fünf Sterne gel geliefert gibst du dann. Fünf Sterne, es war
noch warm. Was auch mal das für ein Gütesiegel
ist genau beim Geschmack.
Geschmack war scheuesslich eins, aber dann hast du drei
koma acht gut.
Was mir in letzter Zeit bei Lieferdiensten häufiger
passiert ist, dass das Essen zu heiß ist.
Ah ja, bei mir auch. Ich kann das nicht essen.
Und ich weiß nicht, ist es dann auch wieder
ab einem gewissen Punkt eine negative
Lieferungsnote? Aber ich schaue jetzt gerade in eine spezielle Richtung. Wo ich gesagt habe, dreh noch eine Runde, dreh noch eine Runde, fahr noch einmal um Block. Die E-Räder wurden zu schnell vielleicht. Weil ich bin natürlich auch sehr ungeduldig und ich schlinge das natürlich runterglühend heiß, verbrenne mir alles. Und ich weiß nicht, an wen ich mich da wenden soll, dass es zu schnell geliefert wird.
Es ist zu heiß.
Ja, ich schaue jetzt da speziell auf den eine Herkunftsbereich dieses Essens, auf ein Land. Indien. Ich schaue auf Indien. Indisches Essen ist oft zu heiß. Ich schaue auf die indischen Restaurants in Köln. Ja. Ihr macht mir das Essen zu heiß. Es ist zu heiß.
Ich weiss nicht, wie das physikalisch geht, dass so viel Hitze noch in diesem Basin, in diesem Styropor-Basin. Ich verstehe es auch nicht. Ob die noch mal so einen Tandoori-Ofen in ihrem Auto haben oder so, wo das dann während der Fahrt gekocht wird oder so, was ja eine geniale Idee wäre, aber es ist zu heiß. Aber wenn ihr vielleicht den Italienern sagen könntet, wie man die Pizza ...
Dass wir zusammenliefern könntet und euch gegenseitig den Ausgleich schafft.
Nee, weil, also die Pizza ...
Pizza ist ja auch das schlechtestmögliche Lebensmittel, um es heiß zu halten.
Weil es ist einfach die grösstmögliche Fläche,
die einfach so schnellstmöglich kühl wird.
Einfach katastrophal.
Wohingegen einfach so ein dicker Klumpen Namen bleibt ewig warm. Das ist ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehrern Wärme vielleicht. Ja, spezifische Wärme-Kapazität. Erinnere ich mich noch, hatte ich in der Physikschulaufgabe, war die Frage, jemand isst ein Essen und verbrennt sich an der Tomate.
Warum verbrennt er sich gerade an der Tomate?
So war das formuliert?
Ja.
Mit Ausrufezeichen, Fragezeichen, hinten dran.
Ausrufezeichen, Fragezeichen und der Name des Lokals wurde auch genannt, es war in unserem Ort.
Also da hat anscheinend der Physiklehrer.
Das habe ich ja immer geliebt.
Da hat der Physiklehrer einen Groll anscheinend verarbeitet. Warum ist gerade die Tomate so heiß? Ich weiß auch nicht, welches Gericht man isst mit einer kompletten heissen Tomate einfach. Warum verbrennt man sich beim Mumbai Palace in der Winklergasse? Und warum wird auch im Nichtraucherbereich geraucht wie ein Schlot? Entschuldigung. Er übersteuert, obwohl er nicht in den Mikrofon spricht. Aber es ist nicht sehr gut. Entschuldigung, welche Formel sollen wir beim Nichtraucherbereich anwenden? Naja, vielleicht fragt man da immer nach im Bordpersonal. Aber ich finde es sehr lustig, sobald Lehrer innen meinen, dass man Schülernamen unterbringt bei Tests und so, da habe ich mich immer kaputt gelacht. Ich war so leicht abzuholen, da habe ich direkt, ich habe aufgeregt vor der Klimatiklausur, aufgeregt, es geht um mein Leben, wenn ich diese Note nicht hole, dann kann ich nicht Medizin in Heidelberg studieren, oh nein, nein, oh nein Stefan und Tim kommen ein bisschen zu spät. Homer Simpson isst zwölf Donuts am Tag. Und nix dir, ich liebe Bildung, das ist der schönste Tag. Ich liebe Bildung, besser geht es nicht. Bild im Schulsystem. Einfach grossartig, immer gut. Daumen nach oben und so eine Kreisblende auf mein Gesicht. Da ich so voll glücklich. Aber Regeln sind schwierig, Menschen tun sich schwer mit Regeln. Ich letzte natürlich auch wieder klassischer Fall, ich unterwegs, Ruheabteil, man kennt es mittlerweile und jemand telefoniert und das ist immer ein tricky Fall, weil du hast über den gesamten Ruhebereich, hast du ja seitlich stehenden Ruhebereich, Guillermo de Filencio, Quiet Zone. Quiet Zone. Quiet Zone. Welcome to the quiet zone. Welcome to the quiet zone. Du hast verschiedene in allen Sprachen. Don't welcome into the quiet zone. Would you shut up? Oh no, welcome. Das steht über den ganzen Waggon, wohingegen, dass man nicht telefonieren darf, steht nur an den Eingangstüren. Ja, aber ganz kurz, jetzt kann man sich aus dem Kontext des Ruheabteils und der vielen Fingeraufmündern erschliessen, dass man nicht telefonieren sollte. Und jetzt gehe ich natürlich in der Mitte des Waggons zu jemandem und sage, Entschuldigung, das ist der Ruhebereich. Und dann sagt der Person, ja, ja, ich telefoniere da ganz leise. Und er sagt, ja, aber telefonieren ist leider verboten. Ja, wo steht das denn? Und dann musst du ganz unangenehm den ganzen Gang entlang deuten, da hinten auf der Tür. Und dann war der Typ natürlich schon so defensiv eingeschritten, dass er gesagt hat, nee, das bedeutet, dass man hinter der Tür nicht telefoniert. Jesus Christ. In welcher Welt lebst du denn? Glaubst du denn, ja, nee, im Ruhebereich ist Telefonien erlaubt, nur in dem Zwischenbereich, Zwischenwaggons, da bitte auf gar keinen Fall, da wo man einfach da da da da da da schön die Gleise hört, da bitte Ruhe, ja da bitte ich telefoniere. Ja okay, aber dann kann man jetzt bei Bahnen ja wenig Vorwürfe machen, sondern vor diesem ignoranten Idioten. Ja, aber das ist auch einfach so dieses Auslegen von Regeln, wo auch einfach man nicht weiterkommt, wenn man denkt, es wird nichts. Aber ich finde es gut, und ich glaube, das schenke ich dir auch, Laserpointer, dass du lächerlich gut equipped bist und dann hast du direkt in deiner Hand so einen Laserpointer, der genau das so einkreist. Wobei, ich muss ja sagen, also generell bin ich ja dem technischen Fortschritt sehr dankbar. Danke, kann man nochmal sagen. Danke, dass wir keine Leitern mehr benutzen, sondern Aufzug. Wir müssen nicht mit einer Leiter irgendwie auf dem Haus hoch oder so, sondern wir haben Aufzug, vielen Dank für Solarkraft, super. Aber ich finde der Laserpointer natürlich sehr, sehr spaßig, aber die Verdrängung des Zeigestocks tut mir weh. Der Zeigestock, vor allem, ich rede vom Teleskop, Zeigestock. Das war schon was, wo ich mir dachte, mein Gott, ist das ein weirder Typ da vorne an der Tafel? Aber irgendwie wäre ich auch gern Lehrer, wenn ich dann diesen Zeigestock haben kann. Kriegt man den dazu, kriegt man den am Einstiegsgeschäft, kriegt man den, wenn man gesagt hat, bekommt, ja, sie haben die Stelle bekommen, sie haben die Professur, sie können jetzt... Nein, du gehst zu Gringotts, wo es ganz viele Zeigestöcke gibt und der Zeigestock sucht sich den Lehrer aus. Und warum ist es immer der Teuerste? Warum suchen sich immer die Teuersten den Leuten? Haben sie den schon mal verkauft? Weil Laserpointer Heinrich gegenüber natürlich auch Geschäft machen will, da müssen wir natürlich die Preise anpassen. Zwar von dem Zeigestock 24 verkauft auch. Ja, klar. Nebenher, Ollivander, Ollivander, dann sagen Sie mal, haben Sie schon mal von dem welche verkauft? Die sind ja jetzt nicht so teuer. Naja, ach so. Da habe ich jetzt noch niemand von gesehen. Sie meinen mit dem Elfenbeinkern? Nein, die billigen da hinten. Ach so. Weil da habe ich jetzt noch niemanden gesehen. Keiner von meinen Kollegen hat die, die sind billigen. Naja, niemand weiß. Mit dem Plastikkern. Niemand weiß, wie das funktioniert. Mit dem Asbestkern. Niemand weiß, wie das funktioniert. Der Zeigestock sucht sich den Lehrer aus. Ich bin nur Oliver Ollivander. Oliver Ollivander. Ich habe damit gar nichts zu tun. Mein Job besteht nur daraus, die Stäbe anzufertigen und hier auszulegen. Wissen wir, was ich glaube? Wenn ich den Teuersten in der Hand habe, dann machen sie einen Föhn an, damit meine Haare wegwehen.
Was?
Und dann kommt oben so ein Spot auf mich, den sehe ich doch da oben, den haben sie doch installiert.
Auch behaupten Nachbarn, dass sie gesehen haben, wie sie hier ihre kleinen Tricks machen.
Sie drücken auf den Knopf unten drunter, oben geht das Licht an, dann machen sie eben Föhn in die Haare, dann kommt John Williams, spielen sie an, sehe ich doch da hinten auch schon die Sonos-Box.
Irgendwas, bei der Einstellung kriegen sie gar kein Teleskop.
Zeigestock.
Ja, und dann habe ich einen Laserpointer gekauft.
Aber ich würde ihn so richtig an der Hüfte tragen,
so in so einem Zeigestockhalfter.
So richtig und dann
Die Waffe des Wissens.
Können Sie die Mitternachtsformel noch mal erklären?
Na klar. Grossartig. Ja, vor allem das Gute ist auch, dass die Professoren was rumzufummeln haben in der Hand. Ja, ganz richtig. Man kann den eins fahren, man kann den ausfahren, man kann den auf halbe Länge machen, man kann den auf ganze Länge machen, man kann den ganz zusammen klein machen. Ja, man kann ihn an der Spitze nehmen und dann hat man Gewichte auf der anderen Seite. Das ist auch witzig. Wohingegen Laserpointer ja auf gar keinen Fall ins Publikum richten, nur nach hinten und natürlich auch sehr klein und doof. Aber als ich zum ersten Mal einen Laserpointer gesehen habe, habe ich gedacht, what, was ist hier los, ich will drei davon haben. Unfassbar. Weil ich fand die so geil. Unfassbar. Ich war auf der, wir waren im schönen Schullandheim unterwegs. Im schönen Schullandheim? Im schönen Schullandheim und ein Klassenkamerad von mir war ein Bastler und hatte eine Waffe dabei. Waffe basierend auf einem Laserpointer. Und zwar hat er sich aus Holz so eine Pistole gebaut, aber dann da einen Laserpointer reingesteckt, so dass immer, wenn er den Abzug gedrückt hat, der Laserpointer angegangen ist. Das heißt, er hat immer sozusagen mit dem Laserpointer geschossen und konnte dann immer sehen, wo er hingeschossen hat. Frage, ätzerische Frage, hat nicht der Laserpointer an sich schon einen Trigger? Ja, aber der ist nicht so wie so eine Pistole. Also er hat lediglich die Form der Pistole auch Laserpointer übertragen. Okay, gerne weiter vorne. Und das war so cool, dass ich das auch haben wollte. Das war so cool und vor allem das Problem ist ja in so einem Schullandheim, das ist ja wie, du packst ja deine ganze Persönlichkeit in Beutel und kannst sie dann eine Woche lang nicht ändern. Weil in der Schule merkst du, oh das grüne T-Shirt kommt nicht gut an, morgen ziehe ich das blaue T-Shirt an. Im Schullandheim bist du ja fest, da kannst du ja nicht einfach das ändern. Und du hast ein gesamtes Mickey-Mouse-Shirt-Arsenal mitgenommen.
Genau, ich habe mich halt auf Mickey-Mouse festgelegt, wohingegen er mit seiner coolen Laserpointerpistole halt einfach der coolste war.
Das war...
Aber schon spannend, dass die auch rot und grün sind, wie Laser-Shirt.
Grün habe ich noch nie gehört.
Doch, doch, okay, habe ich auch schon gesehen.
Ach so, rot ist dann für die Bösen, für die Sith und Grün für die Ritter. Die haben dann, wenn die ihr Wissen über die, über Dark Sidious the War, nee Dark, wie heißt der nochmal, Darth Jesus Christ. Du bist der Star Wars Fan hier. Es gibt zu viele Star Wars Serien, aber ich kenne auch nicht mal die Grundgeschichte. Darth Plague is the wise. Wenn da vorne Herr Wittenbrocker steht, der mal in seiner Erdkunde-Vorlesung ein bisschen abdriftet und dann die Geschichte von Darth Plague is the wise. Wise. The wise. Und dafür soll ich meine Frau umbringen? Ja, wenn man sie jetzt so ausdrückt.
Zeigen Sie doch mal Ihren Laserpointer. Rot. Und dann ist sofort klar. Nein, Wittenbrocker. Sith? Also, ohne jetzt zu tief einzusteigen, aber es gibt ja, ich habe mal ein Jedi-Spiel gespielt, Star Wars Spiel, Und da gab es auch eine Jedi, die hatte ein purpurnes Laserschwert. Also rot quasi. Ja, purpur. Das war aber einfach so ... Warum wählst du als einzige dir die Farbe des Feindes aus? Warum? Aber das scheint trotzdem okay zu sein in der Star Wars Welt, dass manche Jedi trotzdem sagen, ich hätte gern gerne das Purpur, um sich vielleicht weitere Karrierewege aufzuhalten, ich weiß es nicht genau. Aber das fände ich schon irgendwie verdächtig, wenn einer meiner Jedi-Parlawane sagt, ich nehme das Purpur, das Scarlet. Das Rot. Naja, nicht ganz Rot. Das ist ja genau wie alle Fans, die sich den Kopf zermatert haben, warum M Windu das Liederne Schwert hat und alles. Warum hat er das Liederne Schwert? Vielleicht, weil er Kampfstile verbindet, zwischen den Bösen. Er kämft dann nah an der dunklen Seite, aber er hat ja auch das Blaue, er ist ja auch der Jedi-Ritter. Und die Farbe ist ja genau die Mitte. Und dann gibt es diese Geschichte, wie er meinte, wenn am Ende alle mit den Lichtwellern rumwedeln, soll man mich halt erkennen. Hätte ich gerne eine neue Farbe. Und George Lucas gesagt, ja, okay. Und das ist die Geschichte, warum er ein Lila-Annes haben und ein eines haben und dann eins bekommen. Und alle Fans so ... Ja, aber er verbindet auch die beiden Kampfstil. Da haben wir alle damals ein bisschen zu viel reinterpretiert. Aber ich fand es natürlich toll, dass er eine andere Farbe hatte. Plötzlich ist alles ein bisschen grösser als mehr möglich. Kann man natürlich jetzt lange drüber diskutieren. Wer hat jetzt recht, die Interpretation muss das mit der Intention des Künstlers übereinstimmen oder kann jeder seine eigene Interpretation finden zu diesen Dingen, also der Tod des Autoren, kann man jetzt natürlich ganz vieles Kluges drüber sagen. Aber wir machen es nicht. Stattdessen würden wir uns um die nächste Rubrik kümmern.
Ja, die grosse Rubrik Stefan Tietze erzählt. Stefan tietze hat immer tolle geschichten zu erzählen und deswegen heute natürlich auch wieder es kam ja einiges an backlash zum thema peru auf mich zu habe ich gelesen die leute haben gesagt du sollst nicht mehr wegfahren die leute haben mich vermisst und du sollst da bleiben aber, das ist aber nett. Das war der Backlash von Peru? Das war der riesen Backlash, dass die Leute gesagt haben, nee, bleib doch lieber hier. Ja, okay. Hatte ich euch jetzt auch erstmal vor, ehrlich gesagt. Und niemand konnte sagen, woher die Azteken kommen. Es wurde ganz aufgeschlüsselt, Maya, Mexiko, Inka, Peru, aber Azteken immer noch ratlos, immer noch nicht gefunden, immer noch irgendwo im Dschungel verschollen? Schwierig. Ja, Azteken, oder ist das sowas, wo man einfach was sagt und die, man weiß gar nicht, ob die existiert haben. Seit dem 19. Jahrhundert ist die Bezeichnung Azteken für die ethnisch-heterogene, mehrheitlich-Nahuatl-sprechende Bevölkerung des Tals von Mexiko gebräuchlich. Ach, auch Mexiko. Auch Mexiko, sehr einfach zu finden.
Hat unsere Community diese Google-Suche nicht geschafft.
Das ist so einfach nicht, Hausaufgaben nicht gemacht,
aber dann sich gemeinsam abgesprochen, dass man sagt,
nee, das kriegt man ja nicht hin. Dass es zu schwer war.
Eigentlich auch eine geile Strategie,
lass uns gemeinschaftlich sagen, die Hausaufgabe war zu schwer,
wir konnten sie alle nicht machen.
Gab ja damals bei uns auch immer so Versuche,
nach sehr schwierigen Mathearbeiten,
dass man dann gemeinsam als Lassel gesagt hat, nee, die war zu schwer. Nee, ihr seid zu dumm. Ach so. Ach so. Obwohl die ganze Klasse sich so zusammengerottet hat, diese sehr seltenen Zusammenrottungsversuche von den Guten in Mathe, von den Schlechten. Alle plötzlich kamen mal zusammen, um gemeinsam darum zu bitten, doch vielleicht den Notenspiegel zu erhöhen, weil immer irgendwie dieser Urban Myth herumging, dass wenn der Notenspiegel einer Klausur oder einer Klassenarbeit zu schlecht war, muss der Lehrer den anheben, muss den anderen Bewertungsspiegel ansetzen, weil der Schnitt darf nicht irgendwie bei vier liegen oder sowas, sondern muss in einem Dreierbereich sein. Ich kannte sogar die extremere Variante, dass wenn die Durchschnittsnote zu schlecht ist, die gesamte Klausur nicht gilt. Das kannte ich. Ja, wir hatten alle Angst vor, dass man neu schreiben muss. Ja, das natürlich schon, aber das war natürlich immer so während der Klausur die Frage, versucht man zu kippen, weil aktuell das, was hier vor mir liegt gerade, ist eine vier Minus. Ich könnte aber auch auf sechs spekulieren, um den Druck zu... Das ist halt wirklich so einfach all in. Dann komme ich so zu dir mit so einem grossen Plan, wo man erwarten würde, so Mordor oder so, so einem Schlachtplan, aber schlussendlich ist es einfach nur eine Klassen-Obenaufsicht, wie wir alle da sitzen, und ich habe die Namen aufgeschrieben. Ja, aber pass auf, für diese Taktik brauchen wir Jonas vorne. Jonas schreibt eine Eins, ich sehe das schon. Wir wissen, dass Lisa mindestens eine Zwei schreibt, Bianca ist auch beinahe Eins, Fred ist eine Sechs, da wissen wir alle, was los ist. Fred machen uns keine Sorgen, Fred ist bei uns. Fred ist safe. Wir brauchen vorne Jonas, Philipp und Clara. Die müssen wir kippen. Wenn wir die bekommen, dann kriegen wir die ganze Klasse. Wenn Clara und Jonas tauschen, dann schreibt Elisabeth von Bianca ab und deswegen kriegt sie ja auch mindestens eine vier Minus. Das ist doch fantastisch. Das ist eine fantastische Idee.
Du legst deinen Rucksack am Anfang auf den Platz von Bianca, damit sie sich zu Ruben setzen muss. Alles klar? Ja. Okay, eins, zwei, drei. Ah, sie legt meinen Rucksack weg. Okay. Ja, dann viel Glück. Willst du ein Dextro Energy? Ich habe immer ein Dextro Energy gehabt. Ich habe immerhin eine Strange gehabt und ich glaub rückblickend, weil manchmal kann man nicht klar sagen, dass es daran lag oder daran nicht lag. Ich kann rückblickend, weil die Schulzeit lief ganz gut, ich kann jetzt nicht ausschliessen, dass es rein an Dextro-Energy lag. Das ist auch kompletter Quatsch einfach so. Ich stell mir mal vor, wie dann irgendwie so Schüler schreiben an Dextro-Energy, hey, ich hab mein Abi zurückbekommen, eins, zwei, wunderbar, vielen Dank Dextro Energy und Dextro Energy so, gern geholfen. Nee, nee, Dextro Energy würde sagen, gern, klar, klar, nee, nee, nee, nee, klar, nehmt das ruhig. Viel zu viel Energie. Das ist, ja, klar, nehmt das ruhig und hier kriegt ihr noch oben drauf und die Zehnepacken, kein Problem. Ich habe drei Tage nicht geschlafen. Nee, ist ja kein Koffin drin, ist ja nur Traubenzucker. Was auch immer das ist. Ja, und das hilft, weil du dich die ganze Nacht nicht vorbereitet hast. Traubenzucker, gib mir Traubenzucker. Nee, das habe ich immer dabei gehabt und es hat immer geholfen. Dann habe ich immer so eine auf dem Bauch liegende Acht, so ein Unendlich-Zeichen, in die Luft gemalt, um meine beiden Gehirnhälften zu verbinden.
Das hat mal eine, ja, ja, gut, aber ich kann mit beiden nicht aufhören.
Verzweiflung einfach. Du sitzt zu Hause und denkst, hm, lerne ich oder spiele ich jetzt GTA?
Na gut, dann mache ich vor der Klausur nochmal die Acht und dann wird das schon klappen, dann kann ich jetzt GTA spielen. Ja, habe ich viel GTA gespielt. Moment, aber wie meinst du, das Unendlich-Zeichen mit der Hand und das aktiviert deine Gehirne? Ja, das hat mal eine Lehre mit uns gemacht und seitdem habe ich nicht mehr aufgehört damit vor den Klausuren. Aber du musst mit einer Hand eine Acht zeigen. Mit einer Hand zeichnest du eine auf dem Bauch liegende Acht in die Luft rein und die Idee ist, dass die beiden Gehirnhälften ich weiß nicht und ich finde es auch ein bisschen eklig, die Forscher, aber sie meine, die so zusammenkommen, beide aktiviert werden, weil du brauchst beide beide Gehirnhälften. Aber warum denn? Also nur weil du eine Acht machst, oder was? Das ist doch vieler Unsinn, was hilft. Ich dachte, du musst irgendwas mit zwei Händen machen, so oben unten und der andere rechts links oder so. Du kannst auch den Bauchreis auf den Bauch und haust dir im Kopf und so. So was. Jam, jam, jam. Jam, jam, jam, jam. Jetzt habe ich ganz toll Hunger. Hast du das schon mal unironisch gemacht, dir den Bauch gerieben, so jam, jam, jam, jam? Nee, macht man nicht. Kennt man aus Comics, and that's it, oder? Vielleicht Stummfilm. Nee, Bei mir beäussert sich Hunger einfach durch massives Magenknurren, was sehr unangenehm ist, häufig in sehr ruhigen Situationen. Dann, wenn plötzlich ein zermaterndes durch die Menschheit geht, da habe ich leider das Pech, dass ich einen sehr lauten Magen habe. Kann man da zum Arzt gehen und sagen, mein Magen ist zu laut? Können Sie da so eine Art Schalldämpfer einbauen oder irgendwie sowas in der Richtung? Ja, wir können mal Molton ein bisschen. So ein bisschen auskleiden, einfach so ein bisschen. Vielleicht bist du einfach zu schlank. Vielleicht ist es ein Problem, wenn du zu wenig Bauchfett hast, dass dann einfach die normalen Geräusche des Körpers einfach zu laut werden. Auch so die Lunge. Man hört es einfach komplett normal. Was ist denn das? Das Gehirn ist wie so ein Kühlschrank. Und bei jedem Schlucken so ein Einfach so einmal durch den kompletten Körper. Stefan, bitte, das geht zu weit. Du bist zu laut. Du bist zu laut. Du hast keine Betriebsisolation. Du brauchst einfach ein bisschen Schalldämpfer irgendwo drin. Wobei man jetzt auch gegenargumentieren könnte, vielleicht ist es eher bei Leuten, die ein bisschen mehr auf den Rippen haben, lauter, weil die mehr Vibrationsfläche haben. Ach so, wie so ein Korpus, wie so eine Gitarre. Wie so ein Kontrabass. Kann auch sein. Kann in beide Richtungen gehen, weiß ich nicht. Das ist bei Medizin leider immer das Ding, dass es immer in beide Richtungen gehen kann. Entweder Bein ab oder noch ein Bein dazu, man weiß es halt nicht. Es gibt nie eine Mitte, es ist immer entweder eine Richtung oder die entgegen. Aber es ist auch egal, in welche Richtung man geht, man muss nur in eine Richtung gehen, das ist ganz, ganz wichtig. Scheiss drauf. Das ist ganz wichtig. Naja, jedenfalls hängt jetzt diese Bewertung noch im Internet, wo drauf steht. Antisemitismus großartig. Aber zumindest Simon ja, kann man ja zumindest auch viele andere abwälzen, oder? Da kann man ja. Ja, es gibt viele Simon. Also du hast jetzt nicht einen exklusiven Namen, den man sofort erkennt überall. Also du hast es nicht zum Beispiel Frederik Thien oder so, wo man sofort das nachvollziehen könnte, wer das ist, wahrscheinlich. Weil es nicht so viele Frederik Thiens in Deutschland gibt. Noch nicht, ich versuche das zu ändern. Ich versuche das zu ändern. Wieso du jetzt? In diesem Szenario. Ach so, nee, nee, nee, ich finde das gut, dass sich das ändert, wollte ich sagen, auf jeden Fall. Keine weiteren Fragen, wäre er. Habe ich schon The Staircase eigentlich empfohlen? Ja. Wir waren ja beim Gericht. Eine Eule bringt einen Menschen um, wer hätte es gedacht? Ja, fucking Eule. Es ist immer noch die beste Geschichte. Nee, aber ich meine ja nicht die Doku, sondern die Serie jetzt, aber HBO habe ich auch schon empfohlen. Okay, nur dass es nicht untergeht, dass wir das noch machen. Du hast das Musical The Staircase empfohlen, du hast die Serie empfohlen, du hast das Brettspiel des Staircase empfohlen, du hast die gesamte Welt von Staircase bereits empfohlen. Das ist alles schon da. Das Staircase-Franchise, jetzt nicht in Vergessenheit gereicht. Es ist so gut, dass du kein Star-Wars-Fan bist, dafür bist du jetzt Staircase-Fan, einfach so von diesem merkwürdigen, unaufgeklärten Mord aus den 80ern, das ist jetzt deine Welt.
Antenne-Abstellkammer, Antenne-Abstellkammer, weiss nicht, Euren-Angriff, naja, wie dem auch sei, aber das ist mir nicht in Vergessenheit gerät, das jute alte Staircase-Franchise. Der Jute, der altes Derg ist. Das kann ich mir immer anschauen.
Das kann ich mir immer anschauen. Das kann ich mir immer abends, kann ich mir immer angucken.
Kann ich mir immer angucken. Das ist doch...
Das hätten wir das nicht vergesst, das zu gucken auf HBO. Die Gamescom findet in Köln statt. Bist du schon im Gaming-Mode? Gaming-Ecke. Bist du schon im Gaming-Mode? Hast du dein Cosplay schon rausgelegt? Wie gehst du mit dieser Woche um? Du als Unbeteiligter wirst da ja wahrscheinlich nur am Rande mitbekommen, dass die Stadt voller Nerds ist.
Ich bin ja nicht ganz unbeteiligt, ich habe ja durch meinen Freundeskreis im RBTV-Kosmos und durch dich natürlich, werde ich ja so ein bisschen geprimed.
Und meine Primung dieses Jahr ist, dass ich das boykottieren soll. Ich habe nicht genau verstanden, warum.
Ich bin auch zu faul, mich da einzulesen, habe zu wenig Interesse an der ganzen Industrie, um mich da einzulesen, ich boykottieren soll. Ich habe nicht genau verstanden, warum. Ich bin auch zu faul, mich da einzulesen,
habe zu wenig Interesse an der ganzen Industrie,
um mich da einzulesen.
Ich boykottiere jetzt einfach trotzdem.
Okay.
Also boykottierst du auch mich?
Weil du da hingehst?
Ich bin am Freitag da, ja.
Also gehen doch alle hin.
Na, ich gehe hin.
Du gehst hin, privat.
Naja.
Weiß jetzt nicht, was du sagen darfst.
Weiß jetzt nicht.
Ich weiß nicht, warum boykottiert werden soll, aber... Nee, gehen nicht alle nicht hin, weil die ganzen Firmen nicht da sind. Ich habe nur so einen Quatsch am Arten mitgekommen, dass da niemand mehr ist, dass die Gamescom nur spärlich besucht wird. Ich sag mal so, letztes Jahr. Ich bin ja, ich bin ja, versuche ja bei Messen, ich finde ja bei Messen immer den Teil interessant, der so ein bisschen abseits liegt. So gar nicht so die langen Schlangen und die krassen Sachen und die ganzen Hypspiele, sondern ich gucke immer so, wo geht niemand hin. So da bin ich, weil ich finde das immer am interessantesten. So die Messestände, die niemanden interessieren, da werde ich angezogen, vor allem dann die Messestände zu Messeständen auch, was tut sich neu im Messebereich? Und letztes Jahr habe ich gefunden einen Popcornstand, wo fast niemand war, wo man kostenlos Popcorn bekommen hat. Das glaube ich jetzt nicht. Und ich glaube, ich war drei Tage auf der Messe, schon ein paar Jahre her, und ich glaube, ich habe mich die ganze Zeit nur in der Nähe von diesem Popcornstand rumgetrieben und bin immer wieder so gekreist und habe immer wieder meinen kostenlosen Popcorn abgeholt und hing da stundenlang rum. Bei Messen gibt es ja, Messen ist fantastisch, machen wir uns nichts vor, aber es gibt ja immer Halle 1, riesig, Halle 2, riesig und Halle 3, niemand ist da, drei Stände wurden aufgebaut, einer halb, zwei sind nicht gekommen. Und das ist ja die Halle, die Spaß macht. Die Wege sind kürzer und so, weil Messen, machen wir uns nichts vor, ganz, ganz geil, super viel, wir sind ja auch Bedarfsfans, also von so Anglerbedarf oder sowas, also von ganz einfach so Orte, wo es ganz viel von einer Sache gibt, so eine Nische hoch tausend Exponiert. Ja, die Tauch, die Tauch 2022, alles zum Thema Tauchen. Ja, was ich ja auch in Dortmund immer besucht habe, ist die Jagd und Hund. Ja, Karawan und Boot natürlich, immer so diese Bombe. Immer zwei Sachen, die so barely was zu tun haben. Tauchen und Billard. Wir haben uns zusammengetan. Karawan und Hund habe ich nicht verstanden. Boot. Ja, aber es gab Jagd und Hund. Ach so, sorry. Und da habe ich mich immer gefragt. Das hängt schon zusammen, ich sehe es schon. Aber wenn die beide nicht mehr so gut besucht werden, dann haben wir irgendwann Caravan und Boot und Jagd und Hund. Das ist alles gemeinsam eine Messe. Ich dachte auch irgendwann so, vielleicht mögen die sich nicht mehr, wie Arden Garfunkel. Also vielleicht ist dann irgendwann Hund, hat Hund keine Lust mehr. Und dann ist die Hund eine eigene Messe. Und sie sucht sich dann wie gesagt einen anderen Partner irgendwie, das sind die Hund und Basketball oder irgendwie so. Ja, oder Katz und Hund, wo man denkt, das ist eh zum Scheitertreiter ein Verurteil. Das wird zu der Katastrophe. Das wird nicht funktionieren. Hamster und Hund, weiß ich jetzt nicht. So, aber das macht alles Spaß und ist total geil, aber die quasi die Meter, die Fläche immer zu gross ein bisschen, man legt zu viel Strecke zurück und Essen immer ein Problem.
Man ist immer hungrig, muss immer Schlange stehen.
Deswegen ja immer am Anfang scouten, wo gibt es kostenloses Popcorn, stopf dich mit Popcorn voll und dann mag ich am liebsten die Dinge, die mit dem Motto der Messe nichts zu tun haben, gar nichts.
Du bist auf einer Gaming-Messe, aber es gibt trotzdem so einen kleinen Zug, also so eine kleine, für Kinder so eine kleine Gleisbahn mit so kleinen Zügen, wo man sich auf den Waggon draufsetzen kann, bin ich der Erste, der dabei ist, weil das macht immer Spaß, egal ob das jetzt eine Serienmördermesse oder Gaming-Messe ist, ich fahre mit dem Zug da rum, das ist meine Welt. Ja, und ich nenne, wir waren damals mit der Band immer bei der Musikmesse, die grosse,
ist glaube ich Europas grösste Musikmesse in Frankfurt. Hatte euch die aktuellen Akkorde abgeholt. Da haben wir uns geguckt, was gerade in, welche Akkorde sind in, welche sind out, G-Dur out. Ein Stand für B-Moll, alle so mega traurig. Alle raus, auch verranzte Shirts, lief seit Jahren nicht. Wohingegen Asus fiel, war das. Na ja, dann haben wir uns die neuen Gitarren angeguckt, konnten uns nichts leisten davon, haben dann aber immer versucht, möglichst viel kostenlos mitzubekommen. Und am Ende hatten wir alle so riesen Taschen voll mit Kram. So Giveaway-Gitarren oder was, so ganz billige Gitarren? So, und das war immer das Ziel. Was wir am Ende hatten, ist riesige Tüten voll, jeder von uns so 15 Tüten voll mit Prospekten.
Ja, und mit Pleck drin wahrscheinlich.
Nein, Prospekten, vielleicht mal ein Sticker, dann war vielleicht mal der Fender-Sticker dabei, den man eben draufgeklebt hat, vielleicht war sogar mal ein Poster dabei. Ich erinnere mich noch an ein paar Poster von Leuten, die man nicht kennt, von Drummern, die man nicht kennt.
Und so, ganz cool, die Poster, die haben in unserem Bandraum gehangen und haben die Wände damit zugepflastert. Unbekannte Musiker. Auch ein geiler Bandraum eigentlich. Ich weiß noch, wir hatten mal ein Poster, ein Riesenposter von Aki Hakala. Wir wissen alle nicht, wer Aki Hakala ist. Wir haben trotzdem Riesenfans. Ich habe noch nie gegoogelt, wer Aki Hakala ist. Wir hatten einen riesen Life-Size-Poster von Aki Hakala. Ja, Aki Hakala leugnet heute Corona und Hetz gegen Israel. Nein! Man kann ihn nicht mal googlen. Nicht Aki Hakala. War eigentlich ein Drummer von irgendeiner bekannten Band, keine Ahnung, wir kannten den nicht, wir kannten die Band nicht, hatten einen riesen Poster von dem hängen. Das war ganz cool, aber wir hatten halt riesige Taschen voll mit so Prospekten und dem Sortiment von irgendwelchen Herstellern aus Japan oder Singapur. War aber egal, weil wir wollten halt sehr viele kostenlose Sachen mitnehmen und das sind halt Messen, aber uns sind halt immer zu so einem Quest, möglichst viel Kram mitzubekommen. Immer geil. Aber es wird auch so viel Trash produziert, das sind Messen, zeigen das auch. Es wird so viel Trash, druckt das doch alles nicht. Wen juckt das denn? Akjakala, okay, Geschenk. Das muss sein. Aber wenn diese Riesenprospekte mit eurem ganzen Sortiment, niemand kennt euch, Wrangipur, was ist das für ein Name, was macht ihr überhaupt her? Der arme Wrangipur sitzt jetzt zu Hause, hört den Podcast und denkt, Mann, warum nicht? Ich hatte echt eine krasse Karriere in den 90ern, das ist halt vor eurer Zeit. Was ist das für eine, seid ihr eher Metal, entscheidet euch, pick a lane und naja, man weiß nicht genau, was die machen. Aber cool. Ja, ich freue mich immer so ein bisschen, ich bin da zum Glück nicht so viel da, beim letzten Mal hatte ich einen gebrochenen Zehen, das hat so ein bisschen mein Messerlebnis getrübt auf jeden Fall, aber irgendwie Messen sind so das Künstlichste, was es gibt irgendwie so, dass nichts, was da ist, gehört dahin, nichts ist natürlich, so das ist alles auch morgen wieder weg und es ist nur dieser kurze Moment, so das ist wie wenn du so eine riesige Torte backst, mit so ganz viel Verzierung und das ist nur so für eine Stunde so, danach wird es gegessen, es ist so, davor war es nicht da, danach ist es nicht da, es ist einfach so reine Künstlichkeit und irgendwie mag ich das.
Es ist so ein merkwürdiger Ort, der ist irgendwie so nur kurz da und dann ist er wieder weg.
Ich liebe es auch, wie eine Kirmes eigentlich.
Und niemand hat so richtig Bock da zu sein, das ist auch so, weil die Leute, die Schausteller da,
die sind auch so irgendwie so die aus der Firma, die eigentlich auch entbehrlich sind, die gehen halt auf die Messe und repräsentieren die Firma da. Die Leute, die dann da stehen, die wollen auch nicht unbedingt sein, vor allem die Journalisten oder so, die berichten müssen und die dann halt so die Branchen in seine. Und alle sind körperlich am Ende. Alle sind körperlich am Ende, weil einfach 100ml Wasser neun Euro kosten und du einfach seit Stunden nicht getrunken hast. Alle sind dehydriert, Gesichter zerfallen langsam,
alle entweder gehen
zu viel oder stehen zu viel.
Auch da gibt es die Mitte nicht, die Leute
an den Ständen, weil das war immer passiert,
weil ich musste damals in meiner Uni,
stand ich dann an der Messe und
hab Leuten, also Abiturienten,
Abiturientinnen und deren Eltern die Uni
erklärt und stand dann da an der Messe, an der Messe stand.
Habe ich ihnen manchmal auch mal erzählt, man steht halt ewig lang rum, so zwölf Stunden stehst du einfach da rum und erklärst Leuten immer das Gleiche. Wirst lächerlich souverän in dem, was du sagst, weil du das schon neunzig Mal gesagt hast, aber du wirst auch so ein bisschen ... Und auch die ganzen Gegenfragen schon antizipieren kannst. Ja genau, und man denkt, wow, das ist crazy, der antwortet, bevor ich Gedanken hatte, die Frage herzustellen.
Und dann wird man aber auch unkonzentriert. Und dann hatten wir halt diese grossen aufblasbaren Würfel, auf die man sich setzen konnte, wenn Eltern besonders interessiert waren, Abiturierend, Abiturierend, konnte man sich mit denen dann so hinsetzen auf so kleine aufblasbare Würfel, Stoffwürfel. Aber ich habe mich dann so, während ich mit denen stand, das draufgelehnt. Und dann die waren halt, alles, und das ist auch gar nicht so weit hergeholt jetzt, das ist sehr sinnbildlich für Messen, alles ist halt so Makeshift. Nichts ist da fest. Man kann sich nicht an die Wände anlehnen, man kann sich nicht an das Pult vorne anlehnen. Alles ist so, hält so gerade. Diese zwei Tage hält das auf. Es hält sein eigenes Gewicht, kein Gramm mehr. Um Punkt 18 Uhr am Sonntag kippt alles zusammen beim Messen. Und dieser Würfel, auf den ich mich dann so nonchalant gelehnt habe, weil ich zu selbstbewusst wurde im Laufe des Tages, ist unter mir weggeflutscht. Ich bin so hingefallen vor denen. Es war so schlimm. Und ich wusste auch dann nicht mehr, wie man so schnell aufstehen soll. Weil, das ich ja auch schon mal im Podcast erzählt, ab einem gewissen Alter fällt man einfach nicht mehr hin. Ja, das stimmt. Man ist es nicht mehr gewohnt. Auch dieses Aufrappeln. Alte Leute fallen hin und die alte Leute fallen wieder hin. Ja, Kinder fallen die ganze Zeit hin. Und die sind aber souverän damit, die haben dann so eine Taktik, wie sie wieder aufstehen. Ich war so perplex, dass ich da umgekippt bin, flach aufgeschlagen bin auf diesem Messeboden. Alle gucken, die Musik ging aus, alle gucken zu mir. Erst die Arme, dann die beide links, erst mal auf die linke Seite rollen und dann weiter? Ja, dann habe ich mich so aufgerappelt und so. Und dann waren sie nicht mehr interessiert an der Uni. Nee, meine Tochter geht da nicht hin. Da fallen die Leute um. Nee, das machen wir nicht. Geh, hat wir gehen. Die Vorstellung, dass es irgendeine Existenz so beeinflusst hat. Stell dir mal vor, du bist an der Uni interessiert. Der Typ, der dir das erklärt, labert monoton, weil er da schon sehr häufig runtergelabert hat, dieses Programm runter und fällt dann vor deinen Augen hin und du denkst, Jesus Christ, und gehst weiter mit der Tochter.
Und das ist der Grund, warum sie nicht Journalismus studiert hat, sondern jetzt sehr unzufrieden ist mit ihrem Biologiestudium oder was auch immer.
Das stimmt, du hast da wirklich Schicksale in die vielleicht falsche oder richtige Richtung gelenkt.
Oder sie wäre eine grottenschlechte Journalistin gewesen und eine brillante Biologin.
Und dein Hinschlagen hat dafür gesorgt, dass sie den richtigen Weg genommen hat. Hinschlagen? So hies meine ich die Folge auch sogar, wo ich das schon mal erzählt habe. Nee, da bist du, glaube ich, in der Woche hingeschlagen. Das kann sein. Du bist auch mal hingeschlagen. Man kann genau die Häufigkeit des Hinschlagens genau rekonstruieren bei uns, weil es so selten ist, dass es wirklich einfach ein Jahrhundertereignis ist.
Ich kann mich auch wirklich nicht erinnern, weil ich das letzte Mal hingeschrieben habe. Doch, ich weiß doch, weil du das letzte Mal hingefallen bist. Auf dem Gelände der BTF bist du in einem Kabelbinder getrieben. Ah ja, gut, okay, ja genau, das war schon eine ganze Weile her. Ein Kampf, unvergessener Kampf. Da hatte ich blutige Hände und wurde dann von einem Pick-up-Artist angesprochen. Das war ein wilder Tag. Dann bin ich hingefallen auf Asphalt, habe mir die Hände aufgerissen und dann kam ein Pickup-Artist auf mich zu und wollte mir die Hand geben und ich habe gesagt, ich kann nicht meine Hände bluten. Er hat gesagt, okay, Tipp Nummer eins, keine blutigen Hände. Frauen hassen das. Frauen hassen blutige Hände. Frauen hassen Lusen mit blutigen Händen. Manche lieben es. Manche, die es ein bisschen rougher wollen, lieben blutige Hände. Blut da lebt ein aufregendes Leben auf jeden Fall. Ja, also da war ich jedenfalls nicht vorbereitet, bin weggerutscht und lag da am Boden. Vielleicht sollte man häufiger hinfallen, das ist, glaube ich, gar nicht so schlecht. Oder zumindest üben, wie man wieder aufrappelt. Also kannst du das so auf dem Rücken legen und dann mit den Beinen so Schwung holen und dann so aufspringen? Ja, aber fass da ein bisschen auf, weil wenn du hinschlägst, schockiert am Boden liegst, aber dann super schnell wieder aufschliess und weiter erzählst, was das Programm der Uni ist. Schau mir vor, ich fall hin, dieser Schaumstoffwürfel rutscht weg, ich lieg unten und viel zu gefasst mache ich so ein Pfua und stehe den Beinen und erzähle, wie gesagt, es gibt uns dieses Drei-Säulen-Programm, da denken wir noch alle, what the hell? Der ist viel zu souverän im Wiederaufstehen, wie oft fällt der hin? Wie so ein Boston Dynamics Roboter oder so. Oh, huch, hui, hui, hui, ja, auf jeden Fall genau. Das ist auch nicht schlecht. Sollte man mal üben. Das ist wichtig. Ich finde es auch wichtig, ja. Ich habe, als ich Snowboard trainiert habe, geübt habe, beigebracht bekommen habe, da hieß es ja, richtiges Stürzen. Die erste Lektion beim Snowboarden war richtiges Stürzen, und zwar so mit den Elenbogen nach vorne, wo ich mir damals schon gedacht habe, vergiss es, wenn ich irgendwo auf der Piste hinfalle, werde ich nicht daran denken, oh, wie war das noch gleich, wie war das noch richtig hinzuschauen, da ist einfach Überlebensinstinkt und Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, ich sterbe, das ist dann meine erste Priorität, aber da hat man als erstes hinfallen gelernt, ist eigentlich auch nicht schlecht. Ja, beim Judo auch. Alle Sportarten habe ich irgendwann so weggeschoben, wo man erst hinfallen lernt. Nein, wenn das so eine große Option ist, will ich das nicht an meinem Leben. Ich will nicht hinfallen, ich will Billard spielen, lass uns bitte zum Kühl kommen. Nein, erst mal hinfallen. Das gehört dazu. Das ist einfach Teil des Sports. Aber ich fand es rückblickend sehr sinnbildlich für eine Messe, dass da lehnt euch nicht an. Alles ist nur fake.
Die Tische brechen weg.
Es ist nicht haltbar
und es ist auch nicht für Komfort gedacht.
Man kann sich nicht anlehnen, weil die Struktur es nicht aushält
und weil man da leiden muss.
Es ist so eine Art Purgatorium. Du musst da durch.
Man muss dich messen durch.
Aber ich wünsche dir ganz viel Spaß. Freust du dich denn schon?
Wir sehen uns nächste Woche wieder.
Ich bin da nicht so lang. Von daher glaube ich, in kleinen Dosen ist so eine Messe auch ganz cool, vor mir natürlich auch die Leute zu treffen und alles und da wird tolle Sachen passieren. In kleinen Dosen cool, Messen und Red Bull. Bis zum nächsten Mal, haut rein, habt eine schöne Woche, wir heben ab, macht's gut, tschau!